It's great to welcome back to the program
today.
Allan Lichtman, who is a political historian
and Professor at American University in Washington
DC.
He is also author of the book, the case for
impeachment, uh, Professor Lichtman.
Great to have you back today.
My great pleasure.
So I mean, let's just jump right into it.
At the end of 2018 you were quoted as saying,
you believe Donald Trump will be impeached
during 2019 you've been talking about the
case for impeachment for a couple of years
now since your book came out.
Do you still believe this is going to happen?
I do believe it's going to happen, but the
Democrats have to get a little bit of a backbone.
Look, I love Jerry Nadler the head of the
House Judiciary Committee.
He was my high school debate partner back
in the 1960s but I hate the way he is equivocating
backing and filling, putting his finger in
the political winds.
The same with Nancy Pelosi, the house leader,
look Nadler we're in a constitutional crisis.
I agree, but there is a constitutional remedy
and that is impeachment.
The US house has the sole authority for impeachment
and the founders advisedly put impeachment
into the constitution, not as some catastrophe,
but as a legal, peaceful and orderly
means for dealing with a rogue leader as opposed
to the way they dealt with them in their own
time, assassination or revolution.
And there are so many grounds on which to
begin an impeachment investigation, of course,
obstruction of justice, which was articles
voted against Richard Nixon and the judiciary
committee against Bill Clinton by the full
House of course, uh, abuse of power, failure
to honor legal subpoenas, violation of the
emoluments clause of the constitution and
probably financial crimes including illegally
using his charity to promote his election
and perhaps corrupting the inaugural committee.
And of course we still don't know whether
or not he's compromised by the Russians and
that should be more than enough to begin an
impeachment investigation.
You don't wait until you have all the evidence
like they seem to be saying and impeachment
investigations designed to bring out the evidence
and you're much more likely to get your subpoenas
honored when they are directly related to
the sole constitutional function of the House.
Okay, so let's split this into three steps
just so you, I and the audience are all clear
about which one you are predicting will be
reached if we imagined it in the following
way.
Step one is the house formally starts debate
and investigation of potential impeachment
articles.
Number two would be the house actually files
those impeachment articles.
And number three would be the Senate actually
votes to convict on impeachment and remove
the president, which exactly is it that your
predicting.
We're going to see
by the way, you miss maybe the most important
step there.
That's not good.
Once a house votes and article of impeachment,
the Senate does not vote.
Rather a trial is held at, yes, yes.
The Senate automatically presided over, not
by Mitch Mcconnell, the leader of the Senate,
but by Chief Justice John Roberts.
This was critical because this is femoral
and focused and in a trial, the house prosecutors,
smart people like Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff
get to point an accusing finger at the president
to present their case and his lawyers have
to defend him with credible arguments and
evidence, not just spin.
And the focus of the nation will be upon this.
So of the four steps now that you have very
politely added one in between the second and
third ones, I outlined which level of that
four step process are you actually predicting
here?
I'm predicting the impeachment and the trial.
But as I said, I had been bitterly disappointed
by the lack of a spine on the part of House
Democrats.
I don't know what they were afraid of.
Impeachment is the only way to hold this president
accountable, and it's the only way they're
ever going to get the evidence they need to
look into various allegations of misdeeds.
Look, history does not celebrate which of
the fainthearted are Catherine the cautious
history celebrates those who are courageous
and bold enough to meet the challenges of
their time.
And if the Democrats don't act, they will
become worse enablers of Donald Trump than
the republicans.
So let's go through all of the devil's advocate
arguments here.
One is that it could go a different way for
Democrats that actually moving forward on
impeachment when we have every sense that
Republicans would never actually vote to convict
in the Senate, could potentially Backfire
on Democrats in 2020 and embolden Donald Trump.
What do you say?
Incorrect.
That's based on a misreading of the impeachment
of Bill Clinton back in the late 1990s when
Democrats are now tearing their hair.
Look there was a backlash against the impeachment
of Bill Clinton and Republicans lost some
seats in the midterm elections of 1998 yeah,
they lost a few house seats.
They kept control of the house, but it gave
them a vastly bigger prize.
The presidency, George W. Bush won the presidency
in 2000 by 537 votes in Florida at a time
when the vote foul goal was blunted by the
cloud of scandal and the Democrats best campaign
or by far Bill Clinton was kept on the shelf.
Certainly Bill Clinton could have turned more
than 537 votes for Gore.
If he had campaigned in Florida moreover my
keys to the presidency, which accurately predicted
against all the polls and the pundits.
Trump's victory in 2016 has as one of the
critical keys, the scandal key, your turn,
the scandal key that diminishes the prospects
of Trump to be, to be reelected and nothing
else has any consequences.
And by the way, yeah, we have no idea that
the Senate might do after a trial.
One of the liquid rules of politics is for
incumbent office holders.
Their top priority.
Maybe your only priority is survival.
They may not be willing to go down with Donald
Trump.
When you talk about the um, uh, the Clinton
circumstances and how they differ from the
circumstances today, uh, is that a part of,
I mean, I guess, I don't know if you've already
analyzed the 2020, um, uh, reelection campaign
and whether the impeachment question is one
of the ones that your prediction will hinge
on or if you believe that you are ready to
make a 2020 prediction.
Outside of that,
I'm not ready to make a 2020 prediction, but
I am willing to say absent turning the scandal
key through impeachment as of this moment,
Donald Trump is favored to be reelected in
2020.
In other words, the Democrats are going down
the same rabbit hole they went down in 2016
believing the pundits believing the polls
when will they ever learn plus Pelosi says,
oh, the way to win is not by going after Trump.
That's to go down the central line with a
centrist candidate.
Guess what, if that was the way to win Hilary
Clinton should have won in a landslide.
She was the most centrist candidate you can
get.
And the Democrats have nominated lots of centrist
candidates.
John Kerry, Al Gore, Mike Dukakis.
And guess what they all had in common?
Every one of them lost.
So is that advice that the Democratic primary,
it should be looking to someone who is more
progressive this time around?
Well, there's certainly more progressive,
but more exciting.
One of my keys is charisma.
Someone who can really excite the electorate
the way John F. Kennedy did in 1960 or Barack
Obama in 2008 and it's rare.
It's a once in generation thing.
But I hate to say this because I'm big on
the issues.
Issues are totally irrelevant.
No election has ever turned quote unquote
on the issues.
When Ronald Reagan.
In 1984 won in a huge landslide Mondale won
only his home state of Minnesota.
If you took a poll on the issues that Democrats
were ahead.
Well, so I think there's a difference between
let, let's see if we can break that down a
little bit.
I think you're right that very often the minutia
of issues is not super relevant.
So like as an example, Donald Trump up by
those who voted for him was seen very favorably
generally on trade.
Most of the people who thought that don't
know the first thing about trade, they don't
really understand Nafta.
They don't even really know what it is that
Donald Trump was proposing, but they saw him
favorably in some kind of general sense on
the issue.
So might it be more accurate to say that it's
less about the particulars of the policy you're
proposing than the perception that you're
going to take care of a particular issue like
that still does seem to matter to me.
I agree with you David I don't understand
trade.
I'm not sure if anyone understands trade to
be honest with you.
Yeah, absolutely.
Part of being charismatic is making people
believe, and I hope genuinely, that you're
really going to improve their lives and beyond
that that you inspire them to something beyond
the everyday humdrum of their lives.
And the big picture on the issues does matter.
People do not follow the minutia of the issue.
So maybe an analogy would be if you believe
generally that Bernie Sanders, for example,
just to pick someone, is going to make healthcare
more affordable and more accessible, whether
it's expanding medicare or putting in a public
option or creating a system similar to the
one in the UK like that, that level of specificity
is less relevant than the perception that
on that issue, Bernie Sanders is going to
improve your life.
Absolutely.
But it's gotta be delivered with verve and
style and people have to believe it.
We need someone who's capable of inspiration
all of the centrist experienced, not inspirational
Democratic candidates.
And I've given you a list of most of them.
Every one of them has lost one of the Democrats,
Democrats, Barack Obama, Jimmy Carter, Bill
Clinton, candidates are offered something
new and different and exciting and weren't
just another cog in the establishment.
So to get back as we, we get sort of toward
the ends of our time, the end of our time
together.
It sounds like you're saying, uh, if Democrats
don't impeach the most likely scenario, is
Trump reelection.
I mean, is it that binary in your mind?
Well, nothing is binary, but that's where
things stand now obviously it's a long time
to go and things can change.
Here's the worst case scenario in the Democrats.
They don't impeach.
Donald Trump is reelected.
So Donald Trump is empowered for another four
years to undermine our constitution, our freedoms,
our liberty and our national security.
And every future president is empowered to
do that.
And Democrats will be reviled by history and
instead they have an opportunity to seize
the moment to be Richard the Lionheart and
not Richard the chicken hearted.
Yeah, I mean I, that's why I'm having a hard
time getting away from the impeachment thing
because I can understand arguments that it's
possible.
Like I know you disagree.
It's possible that there could be unforeseen
strategic issues with a failed impeachment
attempt.
I understand that we could make the argument
that, hey, maybe Mike pence could actually
get more damaging things done for it.
That's a debate that could be had, but I kind
of go back to, if not now, when, like if this
doesn't justify it, then what are we saying
about the checks and balances and infrastructure
that the founders established for the United
States we're sort of saying it's presidential
immunity.
If we don't move now, we have taken two giant
steps towards autocracy in this country.
This president has done, does not justify
even an impeachment inquiry then what possibly
could be pretty much empowered our presidents
to move ever so much closer to Vladimir Putin
and Russia, which is exactly what Donald Trump
wants.
He wants to be an autocrat and right now he
feels he can just rock over the spineless
Democrats and they're not going to do a damn
thing.
He couldn't care less about contempt of Congress.
He couldn't care less about going to the courts.
He loves it.
And in fact, even if he an adverse verdict
in the court he'll just say it was rigged
and he'll follow the example of his favorite
president, Andrew Jackson, who reportedly
said after an adverse supreme court decision.
Chief Justice Marshall has made his decision
now let him enforce it.
Only impeachment is the proper appropriate
constitutional check on this president.
Professor Allan Lichtman.
His book is the case for impeachment he's
a political historian, also a professor at
American University in Washington DC.
So appreciate your time again on the program
today.
Awesome.
David, take care